[Music]
so
[Music]
it is six weeks now since president
putin ordered his troops into ukraine
tonight in a special sky news program we
get the view of the war from inside the
kremlin
[Music]
good evening it is an act of aggression
condemned as a barbaric attack on an
independent democratic country cities
have been bombarded towns devastated and
countless lives have been lost and now
growing evidence of war crimes is
emerging evidence dismissed by russia as
a sham tonight in his first british
broadcast interview since the war began
i speak to the man who does much of the
talking for vladimir putin his spokesman
dmitry peskov he joins me live from his
office in moscow and thank you very much
for being with us first of all um
do you accept that the first weeks of
this invasion have not
gone according to plan for president
putin
well first of all i would rather
disagree with your qualification of what
is going on
you didn't mention uh the the
qualification of special military
operation
and you didn't say a word about the
reasons for the special military
operation
because it's a war isn't it it's not a
special military operation it is a
full-scale
illegal
war
it's a very serious operation uh with
with the
quite heavy consequences yes
uh i would i would like to start to
start with the reason of this operation
actually it's very important or to
remind you
uh
2014 this is the year when the legal
history of ukraine was changed
during an illegal coup
and after that ukraine has started to
become
uh an anti-russian center
everything that that occurred in ukraine
was aimed against our country
and uh during last couple of decades
actually we were concerned about our
security
nato after the collapse of the soviet
union started to move towards our body
our boundaries yeah and we were we were
really nervous about that but ukraine
but ukraine let's be honest about this
ukraine
posed
no threat to russia and nato is a
defensive organization that also
poses no threat to russia and just my
point at the beginning was that you have
retreated the reason i said it's not
going to plan is you've retreated from
the capital
president zielenski is still in power
you've lost
thousands of troops you've lost six
generals uh hundreds of tanks and other
equipment it's
it's a humiliation really isn't it
no no it's a wrong understanding of what
is going on
about what i've just said
okay well nearly everything
nearly everything well
you've lost thousands of troops yeah
let's go through it you've lost
thousands of troops how many troops have
you lost we have we have we have
significant losses of troops and uh it's
it's it's a huge tragedy for us
uh now about two regions kiev and the
turning of regions
so actually the troops were really
withdrawn from that region as an act of
a goodwill
during the negotiations between two
delegations russian and ukrainian
delegation
and it wasn't it was an act of a good
will just to
uh
to
uh well to to to lift tension from those
regions and in order to show that russia
is really
ready to create comfortable
conditions for continuation of
negotiation but it's just not true is it
because you continued if it was if it
was a a measure of good will why then
did you continue to bombard
mariupol in the way that you have to
devastate that city if you really wanted
to facilitate peace talks you would have
had a ceasefire but you carried on
bombarding mariupol and shelling kharkiv
and other places so it's it's not really
true is it
if you let me i'll try to explain
well first of all mariupol is a part of
lugansk people's republic you know we
recognized them as an independent state
and actually the premier goal of their
creation was to uh was to to to to
assist those people of two people's
republics
that were suffering for eight years from
heavy shelling from ukrainian military
people and by the way during those eight
years
no one would uh
would uh mention that
would mention those atrocities no way
that was just no one in great britain
even if it was true that doesn't justify
a full-scale evasion invasion does it i
mean let's keep this in
proportion i mean
are you determined you mentioned mario
paul is part of it's part of ukraine are
you determined to take mario paul
whatever the human cost whatever the
cost in civilian life
mariopol is going to be uh liberated
from uh nationalistic battalions
and uh we hope it will happen sooner
than later
in liberation you describe it as
liberation so the pounding of mario pole
the pounding of civilian buildings the
pounding of a hospital that's liberation
is it
well hospital hospital was a fake
hospital was a fake and uh
uh we have very serious reasons to
believe that it was a fake and we insist
on that
this is number one number two well now
you did say that one of the the the
famous photograph or infamous photograph
of a woman on a stretcher
which you said was a she you said she
was an actor
she turned out a doctor told us later to
have died she told us to she died so
let's not talk about
that i mean how many civilians let me
ask you this how many civilians do you
think have died in
ukraine so far
i don't want to operate any figures that
are not confirmed or double confirmed
uh we have we have to be very careful we
have to be very careful in pronouncing
any figures because we're living in a uh
during a days of fakes
fakes and lies
let me tell you this
every day let me tell you this so your
uh un ambassador has said there are no
credible reports of civilian casualties
and as regards butcher according to your
ministry of defense on april 3rd and i
quote not a single local resident has
suffered from any violent action while
russia was in control i mean
do you really expect the world to
believe that
we insist on that we insist on that and
we insist that the whole situation the
situation is butcher is a well-staged
uh
insinuation nothing
else so let me just show you those poor
people those poor people and we're
seeing dead bodies there yeah and those
dead bodies there were not victims of
russian military personnel you see this
is astonishing
for you to talk like this let me just
show you this satellite image from uh
butcher on the outskirts of
kiev and this is an image taken on the
28th of february
we have geolocated it to yabalanska
street in butcher before russia had
control of the area it's a normal
looking street let's compare it to an
image of the exact same location
on the 19th of march just a couple of
days
after russia had taken control of the
area and now you see the shadows
bodies strewn
uh along the street and we know their
bodies from this video
speeches we
monsters from this video released i'm
we
know
those
showing now on social media on the first
of april which we've geolocated as well
we have blur the bodies for
viewers and you can see this body is in
the same place as the one seen in the
satellite image the body hasn't moved
the car drives along further you can see
stops at two more bodies again matching
the position of the ones in that
satellite
image and so it continues
with everybody on the street and
you maintain that all this was staged
you're talking about a fake
this shows that dead bodies appeared
while you control the area russian
troops killed those people didn't they
if you have another 20 or to 30 minutes
i will explain step by step why it all
fades
if you have this additional time let's
go on i will tell you yeah
you're saying it's fake so there's not
much point going on but we've verified
it we've geolocated
it
we've got the dates from the satellite
we know pretty well we're now pretty
well the company that uh that has
supplied international community with
these satellite pictures this is a mixer
company that is you know in a very tight
cooperation with pentagon with the
pentagon
and uh yeah it's interesting it's
interesting to know and what you would
probably be uh
interesting to know that uh they don't
have actually exact dates on their on
their uh footage on their satellite
images
so it's it's impossible to to allocate a
an exact date
of uh those satellite pictures okay
let's have a look
we still insist that those pictures
were made after russian troops were
withdrawn from that area okay well what
about this one then because our team has
also verified this next video to early
march in the same area of boot show and
here we see a woman
with a bike named today as arena
philiquina
walking along
yabalanska street when russian troops
were in control
around the corner is an armored vehicle
identified by our team
as a russian military
vehicle so the russians are there you
can see the vehicle fire a shot which
creates a plume of smoke exactly
where arena was standing with her bike
now after the after let me finish
if i could just finish sorry after the
russians have withdrawn this video
geolocated to the exact same spot showed
arena lying
dead on the ground so there can be no
real doubt surely that this
uh shows russian troops killing a
civilian yeah it's right i appreciate if
people are more specific i'll appreciate
if you could be more specific how could
you exactly identify the russian tank or
whatever what it was
why do you think it was russian okay
well i think we we got a still that
shows the russian tower you can see if
you look at that you can see the v
marking
clearly on the side but those are not
the tanks that we're shooting that
suggests
different positions they are they are
the exact same
uh
armored vehicles that were on that
street i mean look we've if we've
verified what you're showing right now
what you're showing right now are not
the exact tank
that was shooting
you have to be very careful you have to
be very careful in what you are showing
just not exactly the same armored
vehicle i mean
so you deny that that happened you're
denying it's happened and you're saying
it's being faked basically
it's some sort of conspiracy is that
right
we deny that russian military
can have something in common with these
atrocities and with dead bodies that
were shown on the streets of butcher
so let's just
be clear here what you are saying to the
world what you're saying to
ukrainians what you're saying to
let's face it the relatives of those
victims that we've just seen there and
what you're saying to russians your own
people is that this is fabricated
it is fake and that is some sort of
huge
conspiracy a propaganda
stunt i mean do you
do you realize how grotesque that sounds
well it's not a conspiracy actually it's
a bold fake it's a bold fake and we've
been speaking about that for a couple of
days but no one would listen to us we've
been presenting very detailed
explanations on various various internet
resources if you're interested in that
we'll provide you with those internet
resources but but to say it's a fake
you're suggesting it's a conspiracy
between satellite imagery companies
between ukrainians between all the
western media
and you
you're suggesting it is a conspiracy
that's exactly what you're saying
well of course it can be a play of fakes
it can be a play of lies okay you can
attach any any date
to a picture
that was made through satellite
okay and then what about well we have we
have to doubt sometimes i mean you
cannot be without any investigation but
you doubt all the time i'm so sure okay
blaming
everything on russia
well let me put this to you then human
rights watch
the organization they've already
documented uh documented
hundreds of apparent
war crimes and these include
i've got it here repeated rape of a
woman in front of her child after her
husband was killed other cases of rape
two cases of summary execution one of
six men
the other of one man
other cases of torture unlawful violence
threats against civilians i've got the
dates i've got the
witness statements we can go through it
if you want but these are documented
killings
with witness evidence and corroborated
by the way today
by amnesty international
and
we've and we've yet to discover what's
happening in
marriott i mean don't you see it's just
preposterous to
sort of issue a blanket
denial of all these things
it should all be very thoroughly
uh investigated i agree with you but at
the same time
we have even the bigger amount of uh
uh
of
eyewitnesses and people who took part in
the
various situations and
in mariopol in in butcher and other
other towns of ukraine
that were uh
that were telling us the terrible
stories of
those nationalistic battalion uh
battalion military military people
torturing people not letting them
leave the town
not letting them uh
go out of the town fleet the town so we
we we also have these eyewitnesses
so i mean
but you know
you don't want to listen to them
we do we've just been carrying a story
this afternoon about claims of
uh ukrainian
walk i spoke to the
chief prosecutor of ukraine on this
program the other day
and she said that all
all war crimes would be investigated and
all the evidence would be passed on to
the international criminal court the
difference the difference is one we are
interested we have a difference
but the difference if we also collect we
also collect evidence and proofs
for
crimes that were committed by
nationalistic battalions but the
difference is one of scale but it is
also that they are agreeing to
investigate you are saying it is not
true it is a fake before you've even
investigated
well
we have to say that it's not true
because we're hearing that everything is
blamed on russia
and we we completely disagree with that
and by the way i would have a suggest a
humble suggest to you
uh suggestion
if you make a story about crimes in
ukraine and if you speak to ukrainian
prosecutor general why don't you speak
to russian prosecutor general to make an
objective picture to present two sides
we'd love to do that okay we will do
that let's just suppose then that you
are
you know what you are saying is right
and that you have not your troops have
not committed
these crimes will you
presumably then you will happily
cooperate with the
international criminal court if you're
not guilty of any of these things
presumably you will cooperate with the
international criminal court
even if you don't recognize that we do
not support and we do not recognize
international criminal court and we're
not the the only country in the world
who are doing that
so uh this is number one and we are
interested in
really independent
and then the objective investigation of
all the crimes
but we want just to to
we we want to understand what could be
the format of such an investigation
because we we have a bitter experience
of international investigations like
with the
uh with the grounded korean aircraft
uh international investigation and we
were not we were not let into that
investigation so we cannot consider it
to be objective
so but so there are other other special
tribunals
there are other special tribunals that
you could cooperate with my only point
is that if you haven't done this
then why don't you just
cooperate with the tribunals or the
international criminal
court
well we're not speaking any tribunals we
don't know about the existence of
tribunals
and i repeat who do not recognize
international court
let me let me put this to you you deny
responsibility then quite clearly
what you can't deny is that civilians
many civilians including women and
children have died as a result of this
onslaught and they would be alive
today had you not invaded
ukraine i think it's 142 children
so far you you yourself have children
you have a young daughter
when you see the images how
how does it make you feel how do you
sleep at night
it's not about my sleep at night
actually
and this is about
this is about
ukrainian military and ukraine ukrainian
nationalistic
military personnel
trying to use civil
civil people as a shield as a civil
civil shield so they are covering
themselves with civil people and not
letting them flee the town or flee they
flee the city and from the very
beginning
russian military uh
were never shelling
civil objects they were just aiming and
using high uh precision missiles
um
to to uh to attack
military infrastructure of your ukraine
because
there must be there must have been one
well sir forgive me for interrupting but
there must have been a lot of ukrainian
military in a lot of civilian buildings
then because our reporters have been out
and about in many of these
towns and cities exactly this is this
one no that i mean it is defies belief
that many of the targets that we've seen
destroyed are military uh targets but i
was talking to you really not as a
kremlin spokesman i was talking to you
you know as a father as a human being
what when you see these images
how do you sleep at night that that is
it was that was really my question
that's a tragedy that's a tragedy and uh
our military are doing their best
to to bring an end to that operation
and we do hope that in coming days in in
in foreseeable future this operation
will reach
its goals or will finish it by the
negotiations between russian and
ukrainian delegation
i mean do you think this can possibly
end
in a negotiation or talks after what has
happened
it can it can it will strongly depend on
the
um
so on consistency of ukrainian position
and to what extent they will be ready to
they will be ready to meet uh to meet
our conditions
boris johnson has said that russia's and
i quote this is a quote russia's
despicable attacks on innocent civilians
in ur pin and butcher are yet more
evidence that putin and his army are
committing war crimes in ukraine we will
not rest until
justice is
served what what's your message to boris
johnson
well uh he's very loud in his rhetorics
about russia from the very beginning of
the operation
so uh in our understanding he's rather
not constructive in his attitude
[Music]
we have never heard any any uh similar
rhetorics coming from boris johnson
during last eight years
when people in donbass were killed by
ukrainian nationalists
when they were heavily bombarded and
shelled
by heavy artillery
we have never heard a word coming from
mr johnson but it is scarcely comparable
does does
in light of what mr johnson has said
does mr putin worry about
ending up in a war crimes court
no he's not
have you talked to him about that does
he realize that it's a possibility
uh
we don't see any possibility for that
but you have spoken about it have you
we've read lots of reports coming from
various countries
uh politologists and then the so-called
specialists in russia discussing such a
possibility but we don't consider it
this this possibility to be to be
realistic
you see one of the problems with these
blankets denials is that
isn't the problem for you and for mr
putin that
very few people outside russia
believe a
a single word that you say about all
this
uh why do you think it's it's it's a few
people it's a great amount of people
it's a great amount of people who
understand who understand concerns of
russia
and who have been understanding those
concerns during last couple of decades
and the world you have to understand
that the world is bigger than europe and
the united states and great britain it's
much bigger
is it but
so but i mean in the last hour you've
just been kicked off the un human rights
council so that is what much of the
world thinks about
about russia and about
the alleged war crimes coming out now
we're sorry about that and we'll
continue to defend our interests using
every uh possible legal means
we'll continue to defend our interests
and to explain ourselves
the problem with the
the the lies that many international
leaders are accusing you of is it's not
new is it i mean look
you can look just recently at the lies
from russia just the recent ones the
ukrainians you say shot down malaysian
airlines mh17
in 2014 the syrian opposition
gasped their own people
the white helmets in syria are
terrorists who belong to al-qaeda
navalny putin's opponent collapsed
because of his medication not because he
was
poisoned the gru agents who were in
salisbury came to
see a cathedral
in 2014 again there are no russian
troops in crimea or in donbass and then
just a few weeks ago we are not going to
invade ukraine i mean none of those none
of those are true are they none of those
are true which one of those is that
which one of those is true
let's start from the very beginning what
was number one uh ukrainians uh you say
the ukrainians shot down malaysian
airlines
mh17 in 2014. i mean you're not going to
tell me that that's true but there are
lots of there are lots of evidence there
are lots of technical calculations
and they were all submitted to the court
in the hague
uh
there is a huge deficit deficit of
of proofs and technical data in the
uh in the court and there are uh
different points of view and the gi
agents in salisbury came to see the
cathedral i mean look the problem here
is a problem
of trust that people don't trust what
you say when you have it
you are a major country
hugely important culturally hugely
important historically
and
people now
don't believe a word the leadership
says that is a problem isn't it
which people
many of the international leaders
most of the west many of the
international leaders
many of them yes they say that they
don't believe
but many of the leaders believe and they
tend to they tend to to explore they
tend to listen to our point of view
and we find their position much more
and much more attractive for us
but it's a problem in any dialogue any
future negotiations
that people
don't trust you particularly over
nato i mean vladimir putin embarked on
this military operation
basically
saying it was to counter partly it's
partly to counter the expansion of nato
and eastern europe well
nato has more troops now in eastern
europe germany is increasing its defense
spending i mean nato is stronger
now
than it was
it's stronger not weaker
yeah and thus we have to rebalance the
situation and we tell we have to take
additional measures to ensure
our own security because we still we are
deeply convinced that nato nato is a
machine for confrontation it's not a
peaceful alliance it was tailored for
confrontation
and the main purposes of its existence
to confront and to confront our country
this is very unfortunate situation but
we have to take it into account you see
nato is a defensive
organization and finland
finland and sweden
uh finland has an 800-mile border with
your country they now want to join
nato as a result of all this what would
what would russia do if
if finland and sweden joined nato
we'll have to we'll have to rebalance
the situation i repeat again and then
we'll have to
uh we'll have to to to
to make our western western flank
uh
more more sophisticated in terms of
ensuring our security but when you say
rebalance i mean president putin has
warned of
serious military and political
consequences what i just wonder what
that means
well we'll have to you know it's
everything about mutual deterring
mutual deterring and should one side
should one side and we consider nato to
be one side
should one side be more powerful than
the other
especially in terms of nuclear
arms
then it will constitute a threat for the
whole architecture of security
and
it will take us to take additional
measures
um additional measures to strengthen
uh our potential
but but would you just very quickly on
that
finally would you consider that an
existential threat because
that is you have said it would take an
existential threat to use
nuclear weapons which you've just
mentioned
what exactly
another another
enlargement of nato
you would consider that an existential
threat
no i don't think so right
would you consider pressure on your
economy or
you know
sanctions that you deemed were to
to wreck your economy topple even top of
the regime would you consider that an
existential threat
well no no we've been living under uh
under sanctions for for a
couple of decades and we we actually we
actually have got accustomed to that
situation
and uh uh
well we we we've started to prepare
ourselves for these
sanctions uh
a year ago a year ago and so now of
course we are in a very tight situation
in terms of economy
but our economy is still on its feet
and we are
quite quite
well
uh we're we're safe maybe not safe and
sound but we're safe in terms of economy
in terms of micro stability
and we're trying to and we even we're
trying to take advantage out of this
situation
uh giving a boost to to development of
our productive sector of our
national technologies and so on and so
forth
and just finally um you've accr accused
ukraine
of being a fascist
regime but isn't it russia that is an
increasingly
looking like a
fascist state all the hallmarks of
fascism the shutting down of all
opposition the
strict censorship of the media the
sinister zed sign that is
um appearing and just the climate of
fear doesn't that all have a feeling of
of fascism about it
no well i consider it quite unacceptable
to to speak about uh in that way about
my country
uh no
the answer is definitely no
the answer is no and uh
asking this question
i would suggest that you just recall
last last
uh eight years with nasa's
demonstrations on the streets of kiev on
the streets of
with people uh who were parts of nasa's
regiments during the second world war
carrying nazi nazi signs and nazi flags
and uh
performing nazi nazi nazi navy
yeah but those nazi demonstrations they
well it was a reality it was a reality
on the streets of ukrainian cities but
the the the last election the nazi the
far-right parties barely won
two percent of the vote i mean you've
got to keep this in proportion my final
question
is this what is to come because only
vladimir putin knows that
presumably more bombardments presumably
more death who knows maybe more
war crimes my final question is this
you know you've ripped away the future
of two countries
immediate future for two countries
russia your own country and ukraine and
my final question is is it all
worth it honestly is it all worth it
the whole story is about future
it's about guaranteeing our future
just imagine a situation when a member
of nato
ukraine
thinking about returning of crimea
attacks russia and detects russian
crimea
and using an article number five or nato
charter
nato countries possessing nukes
will have to defend ukraine yeah
it should be a third world war
and what is being done
is to save
from any potential threat of such a war
but it was never going to happen was it
like that but listen
mr peskov uh appreciate your time thank
you very much
thank you very much thank you
goodbye
there we are a uh insight of sorts a
revealing insight in fact uh into
president putin's view of the war in
ukraine coming up
we'll have uh reaction from the uk
europe and uh
also from ukraine as i speak to the
spokesman for president zielinski live
that's next
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back this is sky news we've been
speaking to president putin's press
secretary dmitry peskov he told us
mariupol will be in his words liberated
he insisted that scenes that appear to
show war crimes in and around the city
of butcher
were staged he described all civilian
deaths in ukraine as a tragedy but he
also insisted that
russia's military campaign there will
continue so all that from vladimir
putin's spokesman much of it no doubt
strongly disputed by uh the ukrainian
leadership joining me now live from
is president zielenski's
press secretary sergey nikiferov thank
you very much for being with us i don't
know whether you managed to hear
what i was talking to mr peskov about
but uh what did you make of it if you
did
good evening mark thanks for having me i
heard parts of it yes
just before the break
so i mean basically it was a flat denial
of war crimes he said in essence that it
had been
all the incidents had been staged for
the benefit of the western media
um
you know um
let's um
look russian officials were telling that
um ukrainians uh had shut down mh17
it appeared
they didn't russian officials had said
that
they didn't poison navalny it appeared
they did russian officials
had said that uh they didn't poison uh
there was no salisbury poison in skripal
family poisoning it appears it was
uh worse mentioning also it it's a very
long it's a very old story but worth
mentioning here litwinenko story right
both committed on on
uk soil
just before the war russian officials
were telling that uh they're not going
to attack ukraine
they were going to attack ukraine so um
all these lies repeatedly said by
russians appear to be false you know so
is there any reason to believe mr pisco
now i i highly doubt
that tell me about what's happening in
butcher and in the other places north of
um of kiev that have the the russians
have moved away from uh what what is
going on and what are you finding there
yes russians actually they didn't move
away they were forced to uh
withdraw from there because they had no
military success during you know during
weeks and weeks
so they were forced to retreat to
concentrate their efforts on the eastern
part of ukraine because they failed
to do at least anything just uh
next to kiev they they failed to even
approach kiev they were stopped uh
again as you said in bush enterprise was
almost those uh small towns to the uh
northwest of kiev so
they left them and as uh ukrainian
forces were
uh taking over those uh small towns they
discovered these horrible horrible
things like civilian muskrains mass
graves filled with uh corpses of
civilians many people were
shot in the in the back of their heads
so clearly executed uh many of them had
their hands and the legs tied
the majority of killed now is more than
400 corpses uh our
uh civilians are civilians
right and you will pass the evidence we
have to sorry to interrupt you you'll
pass the evidence on to the
international
criminal court with you because
will you because
one of the things he was pointing out
was that russia is now claiming that
ukrainians are
committing war crimes uh
will those be investigated as well
uh what do you mean so so i spoke to the
i that he was claiming
that the ukrainians are also committing
war crimes i mean clear
you know there is no equivalence in
terms of scale or anything but
will they be in that will they be
investigated as well i spoke to your
chief prosecutor and she suggested they
would be
yes all
all the
presumed war crimes committed on
ukrainian soil will be investigated
both presumably committed by ukrainians
or russians and uh to be honest ukraine
has a
successful very successful experience of
actually investigating
uh war crimes
of some of the ukrainian troops after
the initial stage of the war in 2014
2015.
they were those
crimes were investigated those people
were brought to court and they were
sentenced so ukraine has a successful
story of persuading war criminals
uh can russia does russia have the same
story of persecuting its own war
criminals i know nothing about that just
finally
you must
fear what is eventually going to be
found in mariupol
uh let alone mariupol we still have to
investigate everything that happened in
kievoblis because after european and
after butcher we have barayanga where
the situation is according to some our
officials is twice as as as hard as
grave as in uh
in bush
so we have to
reach all the smallest cities in kiev
hobless and of course uh
seeing we we're we have very limited
access to
to pictures and from into videos from
mariupol but even seeing that
uh it's really it's terrifying
to
to expect to imagine what could have
happened there because i mean the scale
of the city because mariupol is a half a
half a million has
had unfortunately had half a million of
inhabitants
so um
yeah you're right you're right we uh we
tend to to believe that those uh
um the behavior
of russian troops the
feeling of impunity has the you know
systematic character so the bharatyanka
and the european and bush
unfortunately
um
i mean very hard to say but
unfortunately we believe that those are
not the exceptions that it's a general
rule is
manner of behavior of russian troops and
the feeling of impunity that allows them
to
uh commit such an atrocities towards
civilians okay mr nikita
appreciate your time as well thank you
very much indeed thank you very much
right let's just uh get some reaction
from the uk now we're joined by tom
tuggenheart chair of the commons foreign
affairs select committee uh good evening
tom thank you for being with us
first question really if you heard the
interview with uh mr peskov i mean what
did you make of what he had to say
well it's i mean i think you you set it
out pretty clearly in your last question
when you listed
the catalogue of lies that we've seen
from um
this extraordinary administration of
deception and fraud
you know the tragedy is that these lies
aren't meant to be believed what they're
meant to do is they're meant to convince
russians that there is no such thing as
the truth and that everybody's as bad as
the other but the reality is i'm afraid
is the people of butcher know only too
well and many people around the rest of
ukraine
have sadly experienced in the last four
or five weeks is that what putin is
doing is uh exporting rape and murder
as a form of foreign policy and it's
utterly disgraceful
and
once again i mean it was a blanket
denial it was that the pictures are
concocted
that they are fake that uh
you know they've been edited it's purely
propaganda
but
it's blatantly obvious it's not
we all know that russia invaded ukraine
ukraine did not invade
russia we all know as it's
historically completely proven
many of us have visited and seen
that
russia occupied crimea much as it's also
occupied uh parts of georgia uh in uh
south ossetia and abkhazia you know this
isn't
this is these aren't lies that are meant
to be believed that's the extraordinary
thing these are lies that are meant to
convince you that there is simply no
such thing as the truth they're not
supposed you know you're not supposed to
walk out of here thinking oh well maybe
the russians have got a point you're
meant to think uh that actually
everybody's as bad as the other and the
reality is
putin is a mafia warlord and what stolen
first of all is a great country russia
and he is using his power to murder
russians
across his own country and now he's
using his power to murder ukrainians and
others around eastern europe and indeed
as you know he tried to murder
the skripals in salisbury he murdered
dawn sturgis in salisbury and he
murdered benienco in london so he's
trying to export that violence that we
know him for okay uh tom tugan heart
appreciate your time thank you very much
right uh much of what uh dmitry peskov
said was to deny human rights abuses by
russian troops have we've just been
discussing i'm joined now from ukraine
uh from david miliband president of the
international rescue
committee uh i'm not sure whether you
are i think you're in are you in new
york i'm sorry today
you're in new york but i mean first of
all
these
you know what what do you make of what
is emerging from places like butcher and
those other places around the north of
kiev
ah you just get you need to unmute
yourself david
it's not going well is it
i got you no okay yeah i've got you now
it just shows you never never take
anything for granted even on live tv um
what i was going to say mark is that
anyone who has lived through
the war in syria or the war in yemen or
the situation in afghanistan the
conflict there knows that international
law is increasingly
optional rather than compulsory in the
conduct of war around the world and so
it would be wrong to say that there's
surprise at what is coming out from
ukraine but it should still be shocking
it must retain the capacity to shock
to see that level of sadism and
persecution that has taken place
and i think that those images that are
coming out and the documentation behind
them
speaks absolutely profoundly to the kind
of world that we want to live in because
after 1945 for the first time in human
history laws of war put into
international law and the test now is
does the impunity that's been referred
to regularly over the last two days does
that continue and does it continue to
feed on itself or does that countability
make a comeback
yeah i mean that's the point how
important is accountability and do you
think it can
it can uh come about
well it's absolutely vital because
impunity feeds on itself there's no
steady state in this and we've seen over
the last 15 years
that from the high point of 2006 when
every country 193 countries committed to
the idea that the international system
had a responsibility to protect
individuals under siege from their own
governments that's been eroded
and in many parts of the world in
conflict it's been thrown away that's
how you've seen more civilians being
killed it's how you've seen
more use of chemical weapons in the
syrian cases how you've seen bombing of
hospitals and
schools i saw a figure of 89 hospitals
and schools in ukraine now
uh bombed and so accountability is
absolutely fundamental
to the international regime of law we
may think it's a long way away from us
in the uk or in the us but the truth is
impunity on the battlefield is the tip
of the iceberg because it's propped up
by a set of structures that support the
abuse of power which is what we're
talking about accountability starts with
transparency and this may be an occasion
when social media rather than fostering
hate actually
shows what's really happened and can
play a positive role because the
documentation that's been done including
footage that shows when
different bodies appeared on various
streets in the outskirts of ukraine in
the ielts coast of kiev including in
butcher that's very very important
indeed so there's first of all the
documentation but secondly then there's
a follow-up including by the
international criminal court which has
announced an inquiry which is a good
first step okay and just a quick word on
the broader humanitarian situation david
with the ukrainians urging people now in
south east uh southeastern ukraine to to
move um
it must be
incredibly difficult at the moment to to
cope with what is going on particularly
i'm thinking in poland
well yes the refugee situation is
obviously they're safe but there's a
massive organizational task for the
internally displaced in ukraine about 7
million there is good access but for
those caught under siege in the east and
south of the country
mario paul being the poster child but in
other areas as well that's where there's
enormous danger to life and to limb and
that's going to have to be the
international focus and is certainly the
focus of organizations like mine that
are working in poland and in the west of
ukraine but also want to assert that
civilians all across the country have a
right to international aid and to life
and how hard is it now to get you know
aid further into ukraine i mean i know
that in the in poland on the border area
lev and so forth but getting aid you
know further into ukraine where you know
we don't we don't know the state of some
people
well it's pretty good across much of the
country we're focusing on health on
child protection on cash distribution
and obviously the russian retreat means
that there are more parts of the country
where it's safer and where access can
take place and frankly where the
ukrainian government can coordinate
things in the areas of health but there
are these battle zones in the south and
the east which remain very dangerous and
in the case of mario paul
absolutely strangled and where it's
impossible to get in even the icrc
international committee on the red cross
has not been able to get in so we're
working uh the the fact that the
battlefront is being narrowed is in some
ways helpful but obviously the great
fear is that there's an absolute
pulverization to those who are caught in
the areas that are still in conflict
yeah i mean it does seem mr peskov was
saying when i was interviewing him he
said that
they are going to continue with this in
mario poll and that whole area so i mean
what are your fears about the you know
the coming weeks
well the fear is that we have a
humanitarian churner bill
effectively towns and cities that are
turned into rubble and frankly people
that are turned into rubble as well
mario paul had 400 thousand people it
now has a hundred thousand god knows
what they're going through because
they've had no heat light water
electricity food medicine for six weeks
and so this is desperate straights and
we've seen that in grosjeni
in chechnya in aleppo in syria
there is a willingness to raise a city
to the ground including all of its
people and that's why i think we have to
understand there's a pulverization
campaign the brook's no interest in
humanitarian law international law or
even human life
okay uh david miliband thank you very
much for being with us uh this afternoon
thank you
thank you mom
well there we are that was uh
the view from the kremlin uh thank you
for watching coming up we'll have more
reaction to my interview with vladimir
putin's spokesman dmitry peskov we'll
have all that reaction uh at the top
[Music]
you